dans cette cave coopérative les
vendanges touchent à leur fin et côté
embouteillages
ça ne chôme pas non plus trois millions
de bouteilles soit 22 mille hectolitres
vendus l'année dernière
et si un quart de la production est
exportée principalement vers les pays
scandinaves où le corps navires us a eu
finalement assez peu d'impact on est lui
rassuré on a des chiffres qui sont plus
qu'intéressants à fin août puisque ont
fait plus que préserver nos positions
sur ces huit premiers mois on aurait
signé vraiment des deux mains et des
deux pieds au plus profond de la crise
au mois de mars sur le marché intérieur
à l'image de l'ensemble des vins de
bourgogne
les ventes sont ici restée stable
soutenue par les achats en ligne et dans
les supermarchés les gens ont vu des
vins de bourgogne alors peut-être qu'ils
se sont remis sur d'autres types de
consommation qui leur permettaient
peut-être de débourser - et d'avoir le
même plaisir
on a aussi eu cette impression d'une
différence dans la typologie de nos
clients et des habitudes de consommation
côté export pas de catastrophe mais
l'ensemble des vins de bourgogne
enregistré des baises si l'on compare le
premier trimestre 2010 9 à celui de 2020
- 4 7% en volume et - 11,9 en valeur à
noter des reculs significatifs
américains allemands et chinois ont
boudé nos vins surprise les anglais les
canadiens sont restés fidèles au
bourgogne on s'en sort pas mal nous
souffrons aux états unis on est plutôt à
-25 moins 30
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu de belles
progressions en angleterre au canada
donc dans l'ensemble en tout cas à
l'export la bourgogne tient bien son
rang comme dans bien d'autres secteurs
le monde bourguignon du vin est suspendu
à l'évolution de la crise sanitaire
car si les producteurs et négociants
plus faire face jusqu'à présent la fin
d'année pourrait s'annoncer plus
compliqué